well it's a debate the Barbie backlash
is not making Cox the director of
matriarch and here in the studio
lifelong Barbie fan Esther cracker who I
have to say looks absolutely fantastic
you look that's a look you can keep I
mean we can all agree on this uh also
join my socialist uh and author so she
we can be Associated author actually
Blakely who came his Barbie last week to
be fair but has not got the memo today
plus appropriately stuck in the middle
of his strong female panels Chris Taylor
who plays one of the Kens in the actual
movie which is now one of the biggest
movies of all time and he was in love
Island so I may have to finally concede
that somebody connected with love island
has actually done something with himself
an incredible moment of realization and
self-awareness well thanks for joining
me everybody before we get down to some
serious Barbie related to debate I want
us all to feel comfortable
let's go party
there we go hello in Barbie World
um okay where do we start here let's
start start with you Esther because you
look fantastic and you saw the movie
today I've written a column for the sun
and the New York Post actually same
column just because I feel when I hear
the word patriarchy as often as it said
in this movie immediately I'm like here
we go again here we go again this sort
of construct that or despite everything
that's happened in the last 50 years all
men are awful till they prove otherwise
all women are downtrodden oppressed and
if only it wasn't for ghastly man they'd
be ruling the world you know Lily Allen
said she went to see Barbie and
Oppenheimer and the clear conclusion was
if women were in charge none of that
would have happened right I mean it just
it is exhausting to me I mean I could I
suspected this would happen when we
started having a conversation about
whether Barbie is a feminist icon and I
just thought to myself why does Bobby
need to be a feminist icon anyone who's
grown up with Barbies knows that she's
just a door that girls like to play with
and then 10 seconds into the film I'm
I'm just being shoehorned with this
ideology this you know patriarchiness
and feminism that and I'm just thinking
it's a giant catfish of a film it's like
going on a date wanting to see J.Lo and
then I don't know at the end you see
someone like lizzo for instance I'm just
it's it's completely unnecessary why
can't we just have a film about dolls
the people that made this film have
never seen any of the other Barbie
animals because it's completely
unrelated it's a giant catfish and I
just think it normally canes and no
offense because we're going to come to
you in a moment all again dumb that's
such dumb dweebs
of Love island or something but this is
the problem they're so incompetent and
it's like how can and at the end of the
film they try and say oh but we're all
humans and we're all equal okay but
you've Pace you've painted half of
humanity as incompetent halfways okay
exactly how does that work done okay you
represent the matriarchy which is
another awful sounding word
um it seems to me what it seems to me
what the movie really wants to do is
just replace the patriarchy with the
matriarchy in other words go from one
thing which every woman apparently
leaves is the problem with the world and
flip it round so that the people who
suffer the problem the oppression and
made to look like downtrodden imbeciles
are men not women I don't really get
that why why is it so awful this
patriarchy syndrome and why replace the
p with an m but we're like in late stage
capitalism the world's on fire right now
uh women are losing their fundamental
rates at least in my country uh left and
right we still don't make equal pay on
the dollar we're doing emotional labor
we're doing physical labor as the
beautiful America Ferrera uh as you said
in her her she had a moment and her long
speech that is why we want to replace
the patriarchy which is very top down
into a more communal Democratic way of
living which is the matriarchy and back
when we had matriarchies it was more
democratic there I mean Crete of the
famous island of Crete had a matriarchy
where they didn't go to war and that it
was everything was clear so I don't
really see a downside of this I mean
right now so you think just to be clear
you think if women around the world
there'll be no Warfare I I think that it
would we have different ways of dealing
with conflict than men do and if it was
a majority female lead environment we
would not be in a lot of these
circumstances
never engaging women never engage in
conflict is that a joke I say we engage
in Conflict engages in Conflict we're
humans but we don't engage in Conflict
the same way and I think this was satire
it was Art I'm sorry if some people
wanted it to be kids movie but the best
art whether it's the Wizard of Oz or or
Barbie is really a reflection of the
times it's a reflection of the struggles
and frankly I don't know I saw you said
that you've never seen a movie like this
when I saw that Marilyn Monroe movie who
was a complicated beautiful artist
genius they made it out to be a I mean
it was Despicable it was an assault on
women so how about most movies out there
do make women feel uncomfortable and my
God it's art have a sense of humor there
was satire it was a you know attacks on
capitalism uh climate change Warfare it
was it was fun it was later it was
complicated like women before I bring in
Ken let me just bring in Grace I know
you're not into the whole Barbie thing
particularly but patriarchy you'll
definitely need to right yeah you do
think so into it I'm So Into patriarchy
really exists an obvious end point of
the very successful attempt that we've
had within most capitalist societies for
Liberal Elites to basically take over
and commodify the feminist critique
which was a critique of capitalism this
is a massive box office you know hitting
movie made by a huge multinational
corporation that's going to make loads
and loads of money but also users like
exploitative labor practices all around
the world the problem is you know it's
not like there was Ariana Huffington
famously said the financial crisis
wouldn't have happened if it had been
Lehman's sisters instead of leaving
brothers that's obviously completely
wrong I personally don't even buy the
idea that they're these huge
insurmountable differences between men
and women the problem is capitalism
that's why we have gender inequality
that's why we have racial inequality
that's we have all these different forms
of inequality and unless we get you know
that's it that's by taking down big
corporations like that everything's
gonna say that that's fine I I have no
problem with you believing that that's
fine I'm glad you have no problem I'm
glad we agree that I have the right to
believe what I believe can we just leave
Bobby out of it I don't mind them making
this
yes but let's let's rename the film to
something some pink feminist like child
film let's do that because what this
Bobby film is not Bobby related at all
anyone who's seen any of the Barbie
films any of the Animated Series who's
grown up with it this is not Barbie
related at all Ken is not you know a
half wit Bobby is not ideologically
incoherent in the way that she is in the
film let's just separate the two well
let's bring in let's bring in the
Smokies all right Chris uh Hey first of
all it's really mean so far
I have a historic thing about love
Island which I'm sure is very aware of
let's put that to one side look it's
incredible you're in this movie thanks
which is now one of the biggest grossing
films in history first of all how does
that feel yeah pretty good yeah I've
been pretty we're on large island and
now you're in the biggest movie in the
world yes
no no not really yeah it's pretty
mind-blowing and the story about how you
got this is equally mind-blowing yeah
you go to some premiere of a movie and
you end up or you're not there in your
mates are you end up going to Margot
Robbie's after party yeah and she she
turns out to be a massive love Island
fan yeah including you yeah she knows
who you are yeah and then I started
talking about male genitalia in the rest
of History was this true yeah no I
didn't make it he talked about somebody
knew with a micro penis A friend of mine
has a micro penis yeah as in how big
I've not called Rule around next to it
peers like I don't know exactly you're
telling Margaret Robert it's small it's
tiny it's it's I'd say inch and then you
have a meat from my very large testicles
is that right uh my dad's best mate has
very big bollocks and he can carry and
this is how he managed to
get inside Margot Robbie's head to end
up playing Kim I don't know that is that
is what happened but I I will say I
panicked I panicked and I just said
whatever games in my head and it was
relevant like people were talking about
penises but we're not here to debate
this this is like so intrigued I found
the most realistic thing it sounds like
one of those stories where it's like oh
yeah my friend needs advice about
something yeah and this is how you
basically get you in the movie right
next thing 18 months later you're in
Barbie I mean Barbie yeah all because of
that conversation all because of micro
penises and Big Balls yeah no you get
there you're one of myriad Kens my
impression of them is they're basically
depicted as a bunch of losers and if if
I made a movie flipping this round and
depicted women the way that this movie
generally depicts me yeah all hell would
break loose do you accept that I accept
that but I think I feel like you're
missing the point so I think everyone's
missing the point a little bit like so
it's a comedy right and we're in very
dangerous territory when we start are
picking out comedy and saying oh you
can't say that you can't say that
because then we're going to live in a
world where commonly not something but
there's a distinct political and social
point they're making yeah about the
patriarchy which is round home again and
again again and again what I'm getting
to is is that the overarching comedy the
overarching joke of the entire film is
you're you're looking at Barbie which is
played with by children mostly girls and
this is how they play with Barbies and
Ken's Barbie is the primary character
and Ken is the secondary character that
comes in and out a little bit and is
widely disregarded because the girls see
themselves in the Barbie and not so much
the kids
my problem with these this idea that you
go into the real world from Barbie land
wherever all the women are in charge
yeah and the real world something you're
confronted with this vile Place run
completely by men and they're all awful
even down to the depiction of the
company that makes the Barbie dolls
which is so different to the reality of
that company female president for 30
years half the board now women yeah it's
not run by a bunch of Mad Men Executives
as this film wants you to believe there
is no overt sexism from the company
because it was basically run by women I
don't think Mattel would want people to
believe that I think what you're missing
is the fact that it's a joke and a lot a
lot a lot
of the joke no because listen right okay
listen comedy exactly no grow up I
totally agree
and yeah
what's wrong with that I totally agree
with you my point is if I made the movie
and flipped it and was mocking women
like this you would be leading the
charge I'd be hung drawn and quartered
probably executed it's the hypocrisy
where you're making a very deliberate
Point promoting feminism and using
patriarch is a stick to be all Mentor
they can bring of otherwise and then if
women come on your show and say oh I've
got a problem with this you say oh shut
up snowflake like that is the the whole
debate that we've had in recently it's
like you can't say anything about
anything because you're a snowflake
thing men are being snowflakes
no no you're missing my point you're
totally inside I haven't seen that I'm
sorry I'm not asking for Barbie to be
canceled obviously everyone's enjoying
it but you're asking for my wife and
daughter went to see it in L.A a couple
days ago they loved it right fine my
problem is with the argument it promotes
I'm allowed to criticize that that's
cool free speech right I'm not trying to
silence and I'm allowed to call you a
snowflake for criticizing yes you are
but you're missing the point about why
I'm criticizing him I'm criticizing the
hypocrisy if you flipped it around
Esther if I made a a movie which
lampooned women like this from a very
male dominated position all hell would
break the thing is it is hypocrisy I
take offense of the fact that you think
this is a comedy it wasn't funny at all
and also there is there is something
like this that actually mocks women it's
called a Dave Chappelle special and
every time he comes up with a new
special we need to cancel him because
he's punching down on the poor women the
reality is this film is a giant catfish
and he used the Barbie name to try and
shoehorn this these ideologies into a
Kids film and you can call it a comedy
if that's your standard of entertainment
that's fine and I don't really have a
higher standard of entertainment I watch
live Island I watch Fast and Furious and
also
how are they selling this family let me
go to make you for this how are they
selling this feminist Utopia I'll tell
you how they're selling it they're
selling it by choosing the hottest woman
in Hollywood Margot Robbie everyone
thinks that male and female and she's
making she produces it I think she's uh
right our production so she's making
tens probably hundreds of millions of
dollars as the hottest woman in
Hollywood in every sense from a movie
which makes our all women are oppressed
by the patriarchy forgive me if I laugh
she's the walking breathing embodiment
of someone who's making the patriarchy
look like a bunch of losers it's a g
no I don't agree with that at all and I
think historically there are a lot of
women who had to use whatever tools were
available to them she is beautiful she's
also a brilliant actor she's also
extremely intelligent she's also well
spoken as are all of the women and men
by the way in that film Ryan Gosling is
not getting you know the attacks the way
she is but more that's capitalism and
until capitalism failed which I think is
the patriarchy by the way I think the
patriarchy is capitalism until it fails
people are going to do whatever they can
to survive I mean that is one point at
what point would you have to accept on
behalf of the matriarchy the patriarchy
doesn't really exist anymore and that
basically most women I know are running
rings around blokes at what point do you
admit though I think you're literally in
a bubble and do not open the newspaper
because the way that women are under
attack in the United States right now is
jaw-dropping I mean you would be on an
abortion the ban on women's health
clinics uh women being targeted uh rise
in in domestic violence not to mention
that our pay has not moved in ages
there's a declination in women in
leadership even though we think we
should be at as some sort of um a parody
at this point it's the way that women in
the press and in the public are attacked
by online campaigns by corporations by
uh the writers
have you spent even a minute in my
Twitter feed trust me this this idea
only women get trolled on Twitter
this is the problem when we get the
commodification of feminism is that we
get this idea that feminism means like
every you know CEO of every corporation
being a woman or having 50 of women on
board that's not the lived experience of
the vast majority of women you know
alive the vast majority of women
actually live in you know either in very
poor countries where they're denied
education or they live you know in
situations where they experience
domestic violence here in the UK one in
three women will experience sexual
assault at some point in their lives you
know that's what life is like for most
working classes can't get rid of that by
just saying oh we're gonna like you know
make a couple of you know Prime
Ministers or or CEOs women that's the
problem with liberals you don't think
you don't think young men ever get
assaulted I mean I do but they don't get
assaulted to the extent that women
that's not the point you're like you
know who gets stabbed in the streets is
very rarely women is young men by men
right I think we can agree so there are
different violence is a problem but it's
not there are lots of male victims
violence right I think we didn't say
sections yes I did I said sexual
violence right which is a deep deep
problem in our society yeah it's
actually if you look at it with inside
within and outside the home more common
than what you're talking about kind of
gang violence on the streets and it
happens to women so much and when it's
oh when it's part of a bigger narrative
about racism then it's fine to talk
about violence against women when we're
actually talking about how we tackle
violence against women unless it's a
part of this wider agenda cultural
agenda nobody cares and that's a problem
well I care uh Ken last word to you
I think everyone's just missing the
point oh did it okay it's based it's a
joke Greta go he's done a good job of
navigating a potentially massive
Minefield you're right if it flipped it
would be a different story right
ultimately I'll admit that right but
thank you about a doll that was made in
the night in 1959
but you got to a place
I agree with you that's beside the point
by the way
about women empowerment
of women yeah all right enough virtue
signaling mate you've got you've taked
all the boxes I'm gonna end by giving
women what they really want from their
Ken it's this
I'm not busy let's go party
terrified that's a proper Kim
there's another one here we go that's
fine that's heavily photoshopped not at
all I have no words this is the whole I
got a whole Rafters nothing to say that
is terrifying
I'm speechless thank you let's leave it
on that
rendered silent by the glory of my
kingdom uh thank you Chris
congratulations mate uh Margaret Rob is
one of my favorite ad probably is my
favorite actress I met her in obnoxious
party she was fabulous did she tell you
about how she likes uni no we talked
about Cricket fan of Union we talked
about Cricket she's an Australian
unfortunately now right now that's the
last thing I want to talk about is
drinking uh but well at the time there
was no actually series we had a great
conversation lovely woman very talented
couldn't be happy that a woman is making
hundreds of millions of dollars out of
her looks and her Talent uh in the
patriarchy what a miracle how's she
doing it it's really it's interesting
some woman is able to do that break
through this towering sexist Mayhem
which inhibits all women I know
including these two downtrodden
oppressed female creatures in front of
me who I know just never feel they could
even speak unless I let them right
ladies of course
uh Chris great to see congratulations
seriously cheers from love Island to the
world's biggest movie that is directory
I never thought I'd ever witnessed so
you you can't slay this anymore I can't
sleep
anymore an oscar-worthy meteor Christ
it's amazing and I genuinely thank you